INTERIM BASIS.
IT COULD BE MONTHS BEFORE
JACKSON IS CONFIRMED.
BRET?
>> Bret: LUCAS, THANK YOU.
LET'S HEAR DIRECTLY NOW FROM DR.
SHULKIN.
HE JOINS US.
MR. SECRETARY, THANKS FOR BEING
HERE.
>> GLAD TO BE HERE, BRET.
>> Bret: SO LET'S START WITH
THIS.
WHY DO YOU THINK YOU WERE FIRED?
>> WELL, EVERY CABINET MEMBER
SERVES AT THE PLEASURE OF THE
PRESIDENT.
AND IT'S THE PRESIDENT'S
PREROGATIVE TO HAVE A TEAM
AROUND HIM THAT HE THINKS IS
DOING THE JOB.
I THINK WE HEARD TODAY FROM THE
PRESIDENT THAT HE WASN'T HAPPY
WITH THE PACE.
AND, YOU KNOW, I AGREE WITH THE
PRESIDENT.
THIS IS AN ORGANIZATION THAT
NEEDS TO CHANGE.
IT NEEDS TO DO BETTER AT HIS JOB
AND WE ALL WANT TO DO IT FASTER
AND BETTER BECAUSE IT'S SO
IMPORTANT TO THE COUNTRY.
AND I THINK THE PRESIDENT HAS
THE RIGHT TO HAVE THE SECRETARY
THAT HE WANTS WITH HIM.
>> Bret: YOU SAID THE
ADMINISTRATION WANTS TO
PRIVATIZE THE V.A.
HAVE YOU EVER SEEN -- WE HAVEN'T
SEEN EVIDENCE AS FAR AS THE
SENT TO CONGRESS SAYING THAT.
IS THERE ANY DIRECT
COMMUNICATION WITH CONGRESS THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION WANTS TO
PRIVATIZE THE V.A.?
>> NO, BRET, I ACTUALLY HAVEN'T
SAID THAT.
I WAS PART OF THE ADMINISTRATION
UNTIL YESTERDAY.
WE ARE NOT TRYING TO PRIVATIZE
THE V.A.
WE ARE TRYING TO IMPROVE AND
TRANSFORM THE V.A.
WHAT I SAID IN MY EDITORIAL IS
THAT THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
POLITICAL APPOINTEES WITHIN V.A.
THAT ARE PUSHING TO PRIVATIZE
MUCH FASTER THAN I THINK IS IN
THE INTEREST OF A SAFE WAY TO
CARE FOR OUR VETERANS AND I'VE
STOOD UP FOR THEM BECAUSE I WAS
IN WASHINGTON AND I WAS WORKING
FOR THE PRESIDENT ON BEHALF OF
OUR VETERANS.
>> Bret: WHY DID YOU FEEL THE
NEED TO WRITE THE OP ED?
>> LISTEN, I CAME TO WASHINGTON
FROM THE PRIVATE SECTOR FOR ONE
REASON TO FIX THE V.A.
I KNOW THIS MATTERS A LOT TO THE
PRESIDENT.
AND WE, AS A COUNTRY, HAVE A
LONG WAY TO GO TO GET THE V.A.
IN PROPER SHAPE.
BUT IT WOULD BE A MISTAKE TO
CONCLUDE THAT WE DO NOT NEED THE
V.A. AND THAT WE HAVE TO
DISMANTLE THE V.A.
WE HAVE TO IMPROVE THE V.A.
WHILE AT THE SAME TIME, WORKING
WITH THE PRIVATE SECTOR IN
INTEGRATED WAY TO MEET THE NEEDS
OF OUR VETERANS.
>> Bret: YOU KNOW, WE HEARD THIS
SOUNDBITE IN LUCAS' PIECE FROM
SENATOR MORAN QUESTIONING YOUR
DEALINGS WITH THAT PARTICULAR
COMMITTEE.
DID YOU HAVE A CREDIBILITY ISSUE
WITH CONGRESS?
>> OH, I DON'T THINK SO.
YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER, I'M THE
ONLY CABINET MEMBER THAT HAD
100-0 VOTE.
I PRIDED MYSELF IN WORKING IN A
BIPARTISAN WAY.
SENATOR MORAN FELT STRONGLY
ABOUT PUSHING TO GIVE VETERANS
ADDITIONAL OPTIONS THAT,
FRANKLY, HIS OWN SENATORS, THE
COMMITTEE DIDN'T AGREE WITH.
HE LOST HIS AMENDMENT 14-1.
HE WAS THE ONLY ONE VOTING
AGAINST IT.
AND HE WAS FRUSTRATED BY THAT.
BY THE WAY, YOU KNOW, HE HAD
SOME REASONABLE POINTS THERE.
SO THERE ARE MANY THINGS THAT HE
AND I AGREED UPON BUT IN THE
END, HE DIDN'T LIKE THE POSITION
THAT I TOOK WHICH WAS TO DO WHAT
I THOUGHT WAS THE RIGHT THING
FOR OUR VETERANS.
>> Bret: ABOUT 11 MONTHS AGO, I
HAD YOU ON "SPECIAL REPORT" AND
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES.
TAKE A LISTEN.
ARE YOU SEEING CHANGE?
>> WE'RE IN THE INTENSIVE CARE
UNIT AND WE'RE MONITORING THINGS
REALLY CLOSELY.
BUT I AM OPTIMISTIC THAT WE'RE
BEGINNING TO FINALLY DEAL WITH
THE ISSUES THAT HAVE PLAGUED THE
V.A. SYSTEM FOR DECADES.
>> Bret: SO THE PRESIDENT SAID
TODAY THAT HE JUST WASN'T HAPPY
HOW FAST OR HOW THINGS WERE
GOING.
THAT THEY WERE GOING TOO SLOWLY.
WHAT'S YOUR RESPONSE TO THAT AND
WHAT CAN BE DONE TO CHANGE THAT
PACE?
>> WELL, I DON'T THINK THE
PRESIDENT SHOULD BE HAPPY WITH
WHERE WE WERE, AND AS SECRETARY,
I WASN'T HAPPY WITH WHERE WE
WERE.
WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
MOVE THIS BUREAUCRACY FASTER AND
BE MORE RESPONSIVE.
WHEN YOU SHOWED THEM, I KNOW
THEM VERY WELL AND, FRANKLY,
THIS WAS A SYSTEM THAT FAILED
THEM AND WE SHOULDN'T BE DOING
THAT.
THIS IS A SYSTEM THAT NEEDS TO
BE PUSHED.
MANY OF THE BUREAUCRATIC
ELEMENTS NEED TO BE
RESTRUCTURED.
I'VE STARTED THAT PROCESS.
I HOPE THAT DR. JACKSON WILL
CONTINUE THAT PROCESS BECAUSE IT
NEEDS TO BE DONE.
>> Bret: YOU KNOW, YOU HAD THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL, OBVIOUSLY,
COME OUT WITH THIS SCATHING
REPORT ABOUT YOUR TRIP TO
EUROPE.
WE'VE BEEN OVER THAT.
AND YOUR RESPONSE TO THAT.
WERE THERE OTHER I.G.
INVESTIGATIONS OR AUDITS THAT
WE'RE FACTORING INTO THIS WHOLE
THING?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, WASHINGTON IS
A TOWN THAT THROWS UP ALL SORTS
OF ALLEGATIONS.
THERE WERE ALLEGATIONS OF
ADDITIONAL REPORTS.
BUT THERE HAVE BEEN NO OTHER
REPORTS THAT HAVE COME OUT.
AND I'VE ADDRESSED THAT
EVERYTHING THAT I DID ON THIS
EUROPEAN TRIP WAS PREAPPROVED BY
ETHICS.
WAS CONSISTENT WITH PAST
POLICIES IN V.A. BUT WHEN THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL HAD CONCERNS
ABOUT IT, I WROTE A CHECK AND I
PAID BACK EVERY PENNY OF A
SINGLE COACH AIR FARE.
THAT WAS THE TOTAL AMOUNT THAT
GOVERNMENT FUNDS WERE USED FOR.
AND I PAID THAT BACK.
SO LOOK, I THINK I'VE ADDRESSED
THAT.
THIS WAS USED IN A POLITICAL WAY
TO TRY TO REMOVE ME.
AND, YOU KNOW, THIS IS
WASHINGTON.
I'M A BIG BOY.
I UNDERSTAND THAT.
I'VE SAID THAT IT SHOULDN'T BE
THIS HARD TO SERVE YOUR COUNTRY,
AND I DON'T THINK IT SHOULD BE.
BUT THANKFULLY, THERE WERE MANY
PEOPLE THAT ARE STILL TRYING TO
FIX
FI
FIX.
>> Bret: SHE HAD HE GET
CONFIRMED, WHAT WOULD IT BE?
>> TO MAKE SURE THAT HE'S
CONSISTENT WITH THE PRESIDENT'S
AGENDA, TO PUSH REALLY HARD,
ALWAYS TO KEEP THE VETERANS'
INTEREST AT HEART.
THAT MIKE
THAT MIK
THAT MAK
THAT MAKE
THAT MAKE S
THAT MAKE SUR
THAT MAKE SURE
THAT MAKE SURE H
THAT MAKE SURE HE'
THAT MAKE SURE HE'S
THAT MAKE SURE HE'S W
THAT MAKE SURE HE'S WOR
THAT MAKE SURE HE'S WORKI
THAT MAKE SURE HE'S WORKING
THAT MAKE SURE HE'S WORKING W
THAT MAKE SURE HE'S WORKING WIT
THAT MAKE SURE HE'S WORKING WITH
CONGRESS IN A BIPARTISAN WAY AND
MAKE SURE HE'S LISTENING TO THE
VETERANS GROUPS.
FRANKLY, THAT'S WHY WE'RE DOING
THIS.
THAT'S WHAT A RESPONSIVE
ORGANIZATION NEEDS TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IN DOING IS LISTENING
TO THOSE THAT IT SERVES.
SO I WILL HELP DR. JACKSON IN
ANY WAY THAT HE NEEDS HELP,
BECAUSE IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT
WE SUCCEED AT THIS MISSION.